[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
mitzi had made me a paid regular at la
jolla or at
no what i got lucky so two years in
paulie called me and goes dude i saw you
an open mic
and i'm looking for an emcee for my
vegas show
and i go i was working the door in la
jolla and i go
all right yeah so he flew me out there
and it was in front of
this he was huge at the time five
thousand people where was it at invading
top of the river wow
right so steve schrippa was like the guy
there
you know yes 5 000 people yeah and i
remember stripper going
it did and he called me ching
because dice should call me ching what
yeah dice used to call me ching
c-h-i-n-g c-h-i-n-k
yeah so he's eager what are you saying
which one are you saying ching
with a g oh my god yeah not [ __ ]
not [ __ ] that's illegal no it's not
it's cancelled
you can't you could have said it back
then we said it all the time
yeah you guys did just a shane gillis
got cancelled from it that's now
back then but essentially you get a
micro needling which is like little tiny
meals and then it brings your blood to
the surface which is like really healthy
for your skin and then
they can inject all sorts of stuff into
your face yeah but
what are they putting in there listen
well it's this this way in which
um one forces uh through micro needling
um it's like a little roller with these
some of you i don't think many of you
know it and it pushes
through the skin and ruptures the
collagen and then boost it you look like
a burn victim for a day but then it's
but then it pushes what are you pushing
into the skin sarah sandra sarah
said kerry what are you pushing into the
skin
well you push in whatever the facialist
would like to insert into your pores but
what is it
it is an extraction from a
um a a a piece of skin
uh that came from a young person
um far far away and they somehow figured
out how to extract
it's foreskin from a korean baby
[Laughter]
cause that that's real
she's putting korean baby penises in her
face
and there are korean babies thousands of
them going
where's my penis where's the rest of my
pants
it's right here it's my cheekbones
how do you say penis in korean yeah how
do you say penis you know if i i don't
gochu gochu yeah where is mykocho
it's right here right hey i'm gonna tell
you this right now yeah
if i was one of those korean babies yeah
when i get older
i'm coming to l.a i'm knocking on
her door yeah want it back
just grab her face get out take it out i
want it back
how about this we can start your
a-a-i-a-a-p-i yeah
p.s no i'm that's the new campaign
no more corruption asians being violated
against that stuff that's the real crime
because korean specific no more korean
foreskin facials yeah no more korean
food skins
no more korean for skin facials no more
korean foreskin face
dude if you don't want to participate in
aapi yeah and stop asian hey if you
don't want to be here
get the [ __ ] out of here jules
no no more korean foreskin facials no
more korean foreskin facials
no more korean foreskins facial there we
go i mean it's like
minimal you don't have to go to the
protest okay have you ever pooped
outside
i poop outside now huh yeah you have
some
bathrooms what have you ever pooped
outside i poop outside
now what i pooed i'll tell you where i
pooed last
that's outside my house yeah in the back
seat of my prius
stop it in the car you still own not
even in a bag
all over the seats who's cleaning it do
you clear it no no yeah
kaleidoscope cleaned it why did you do
that
would it be why i had to go get out
no i love that movie you pooped in the
car
i was on um where was i i was on the 101
mm-hmm
it was trafficking trafficking you're
right is that a word yeah a lot of
traffic
trafficking sounds more fun yeah it's
just trafficking it was trafficking and
i have what i call um irritable bowel
syndrome no i don't have that
right i have um
i gotta go now syndrome it sounds like
you
i gotta go now syndrome i think that's
the same thing yeah i don't know yeah
but that's what i have are your bowels
irritable no do they get upset easily
but it it comes on sudden like that's
ibs that's 9 11. that's ibs
it is that's what irritable bodies are
on 9 11 like you woke up what's going on
yeah that's you yeah that's me except
except your pants are the buildings are
you circumcised
yeah bro when they when they i still
have mine when they circumstance
you sell it to sandy i could you could
it's pretty old though
so what you just it'll still be good
it'll still be good
all right they circumcised when they
circumcised me they saw what was left
and they asked my mom if i they should
put it back
they asked if they could put it back
because it was so tiny that they were
like
it's going to be tough for him should we
put it back down
right right they were going to put it
back do you see
i you know i have it did you make a
decision they don't ask the baby that
should they cut it do you put it back
and i was like
that is so weird that they cut baby boys
penises yeah isn't that gross
first of all can i just say let me ask
you another question about this about
this i don't know what all i know is
this clip okay but let me just ask a
question
so before so i imagine you're in korea
i'm a creative you're a surgeon yo
you're you you deliver babies your
doctor
got it right baby's born you clip the
[ __ ] force again
whose idea is it
at first to go maybe this
could go well you know what so you know
so funny what happened he clipped the
foreskin and then he put it on his
cheeks one of the
one of the surgeons and one as a joke as
a joke everyone laugh and their nurses
go skin look beautiful
[Laughter]
he put a bunch of little baby foreskins
all over his face as a joke yeah
right oh look at me look at me right
[Music]
then and then everyone's kind of bit and
then one nurse goes hey
you look young
[Laughter]
one time i had um
korean barbecue with my girlfriend we
did it we did one on sixth street i want
to say this place's name but it's
popular because it's cheaper and it's
it's all you can eat sixth street in
santa monica no sixth street in korea
town oh korea town downtown
and as soon as we got out of there we're
driving down
western bubble guts i pull over
off of one of the streets in western i
ran to a man's house
and clyde's like what are you doing and
i sprayed
on the side of his house
what do you wipe with nothing you just
get pants up nature's breeze
the air so i was living in san diego in
a regular but
mensie goes hey dude hey bro you come up
and do
you know come to l.a bro
so i went up there on a saturday night
and mitzi saw me there
and i was hanging out with carlos in the
main room green room
and carlos goes hey mitzi put him up
[Music]
right you're a new comic i'm new yeah
and
and mitzi goes yeah you go up and joe
rokin says joe rogan's there
and joe rogan goes missy he's [ __ ]
san diego he's not funny or something
like that
he's not [ __ ] funny right yeah he'll
be fine
that's what she said yeah i went up
there
not only did i not hear any laughs i
hear rogan in the background
i [ __ ] told you he's not funny he's
not a [ __ ] funny mitzi's lawyer
yeah right and i remember eating it so
bad
you can feel it oh my god it was also
like
one of those sets where i went oh maybe
it's i'm not gonna make it
yeah oh you know maybe yeah maybe it's
just like i was a local
yeah in san diego what who am i
competing against you know right
but maybe in the big leagues i just
don't have it
in retrospect is because i just didn't
wasn't you weren't ready i wasn't ready
that's all you were good you just
weren't ready i wasn't even good i
wasn't even good
it was just like i just knew it wasn't
ready can you give me one of your jokes
that bomb does yeah oh yeah yeah i used
to do um
i'm so lonely right
i'm so lonely when i used to when i
masturbate
i grab my own ass right and i go
and then i turn around i go do me do me
and i start squeezing
and then my opening act my opening line
was i used to make my hair really messy
yeah so it was out of control and i
would go
i'm not really asian i just woke up
oh my god when i first saw you you know
what i thought
i'd be honest because i was being honest
no no joke i said
that's that crazy guy that gets naked
all the time at the comedy store
that's literally what i thought to
myself that's that crazy guy that gets
naked at the comedy store
i won't do it again again what when do
you get naked when they get naked
all the time when all the time no
no no don't google it don't google it
because you're gonna find i could google
you
and find something andrew
santino
naked naked just naked okay
images
no we got to blur that well yeah you got
a blur right there because that's boobs
well that's that's on set of a show that
i had my penis wrapped
that's me on set of i'm dying up here
there we go you're naked
no that's on you i don't give a [ __ ]
you're naked it's on a tv show i'll show
you now
google me then that's enough you won't
find anything
okay okay all right you won't find
anything and this won't be on a tv show
it if it's performing too it doesn't
matter oh my god i won't find it
the first eight pictures are of you on
stage performing
the same thing as a tv show no yes
performing this is on tom green's show
performing
performing this is on at a radio station
performing
performing bobby lee naked on stage
performing
this is you at your house performing not
performing but i love how you say i
don't get naked
look at how many naked photos come up
it's almost insane
it's almost absurd how many come on
there's you
you and i let's say you and i are
playing a plane crash we're the only
survivors where you and i end up on a
deserted island
okay you wouldn't want i would be the
last person you'd want there
why because i would have to say i'd go
tribal real quick you tried to kill me
yeah like as soon as we got on the beach
you'd look up i'd be completely naked
with a spear
trying to have like like some sort of
like makeup on my face
and be like and i'd just speak the
language immediately yeah immediately
yeah wow
already like you know like in um a
return of the jedi when they took uh
uh um han solo and they were in the
rotisserie the ewoks
oh yeah yeah you'd be already in that
yeah i mean so you would kill me you
think you'd kill me
my whole thing is i think see my
scenario is we crash on an island
i'm i have to gather and collect
everything because you're laying down
[Laughter]
you're finding a way to play candy crush
on the sand in the sand
no i would need to probably rest because
i would
honestly like honestly i would be like
on the beach like this and i'd be
first probably sunburned as [ __ ] see i
would i would and then i'd be looking up
and you're like chopping things down i'd
be climbing a tree getting coconuts i'm
going outside right and i'd just be less
laying and i would probably contemplate
my life like
why am i [ __ ] on this island with
this piece of [ __ ] see after two days of
no water and you not doing anything to
try to get food for us
i would have one of those nightmares in
the middle of the night where i grab a
coconut
and i smash it over your head because i
think he's got protein
i can eat him without a doubt yeah you
know i would see you and i go because
i'd lose a lot of weight really fast
because i knew that i would know that
about you
yeah yeah i'd already have the spear
ready to go really right up front but
the moment
i die are you going to try to eat me i'd
probably [ __ ] you first
[ __ ] me and then right when the body is
warm yeah yeah i mean still warm she'd
[ __ ] me
because i probably won't have a warm
hole for a very long time
i can promise you that when i kill you i
won't eat you or i won't [ __ ] you yeah
oh really
i wouldn't [ __ ] you would it be funny if
i [ __ ] you ate you and i walked across
to the island as a resort
yeah i'm in maui and then they're like
why is that naked guy with the spear
with the big
blood dripping from your mouth and just
like yeah what does he have
red hairs in his teeth is this bumpy
no no that's the sister bong oh so this
was bong
bong ming yeah liked the wing sister one
of the wing sisters and i don't
remember because there was triplets
there was three wing sisters but bong
ming i do remember her bong ming loved
one of the wings at triplets
they caught them making love scissoring
scissoring well i don't know what it
called in chinese but well they had
chopsticks they were chopsticked and
anyway that was crazy
you say something like that they were
sticking that was insane
bong ming and one of the in one of the
wings all right so
making love these two emperors let me
just stop it for a second got it
so let me just get this straight okay
all right that's right
so the wing yeah the wingding sisters
the emperor had three sisters had three
sisters triplets they had their triplets
correct okay
and the ming dynasty had one one girl
right with scissoring one of these girls
she was stopped chopstick and
the chopsticks i've chopped up my bad
she was chopping chopsticking one of
these sisters the middle child i think
you don't know for sure i'm not positive
because they look the same it could have
been either one
they were triplets yeah exactly they
didn't look the same they were like
anyways no
it was triple so it could have been
anybody true
[Music]
my
[Music]